as you can see this is my room
um it is like very similar to your hotel
room i have everything and nothing in
this room actually goes out
for ten days these four walls were all
harun knew
two doors isolated him from the outside
world
every single bottle every single
paracetamol every single iv everything
all the needles everything they use on
me
stays in this room he was rushed to the
royal free hospital in north london with
a high fever
an early symptom of his monkey pox
infection
lesions and scabs in his throat meant
harun couldn't eat or swallow he was fed
through a tube in his arm
it is one of the most extreme cases of
monkey pox ever seen
in the uk
haroon has only just been discharged
from hospital but he is still in
quarantine
i am by myself alone um
i don't have any family here rather than
my my good couple of good friends
i it was very scary i thought that i'm
by myself i can't do this alone
and not being able to get help from
frontline services was very scary
haroon called the nhs one one one
helpline after having a fever of over 39
degrees for a number of consecutive days
and every single time
uh i heard the the answer that god said
call us when you are getting worse
and i was already diverse i uh checked
my throat and my throat was all white uh
with the with the you know i don't know
pus or
some infection
it got to a stage that i couldn't even
swallow my own spirit
monkeypox is not but can present like an
sti sexual health clinics are usually
the first to identify the symptoms
monkey pox cases have trebled across
europe in the past two weeks and the
world health organization is warning
that they can be no room for complacency
vaccinations are being offered to some
communities here in the uk but the fear
is that this rollout just isn't
happening quickly enough
but the government's response has been
severely criticized for being too slow
and inadequate by a coalition of the
country's leading sexual health service
providers
it warns of vaccine shortages and says
monkey pox risks becoming endemic
in this country we are united in calling
for urgent action to prevent monkey pox
becoming endemic in the uk
since may 2022 the uk monkey box
outbreak has become a crisis with case
numbers rising steeply clinics are
overwhelmed
although the outbreak was unexpected
public health strategies have failed we
need urgent action now to eliminate
monkey pox in the uk
it looks like we are in for
an outbreak that's going to last for the
rest of the year at least before it's
averted what we would like to do is to
be able to have access to more vaccine
more quickly and be able to distribute
it more effectively and all of that
requires resource
haroon's ordeal is coming to an end but
the monkey pox outbreak is growing
ashish joshi sky news in east london